herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute mal wieder mit lara mit meiner
freundin und ihr habt bereits viel
gelesen wir bestellen heute wieder aber
lassen den zufall entscheiden genau
genommen siri sowie letztens nicht der
allergrößte verdoppelt endlich schon
neue sachen aber wenn wir essen
bestellen dann ist manchmal ein bisschen
komplizierter sagt derjenige der keine
paprika keine bananen
ja und da sind die einzigen beiden
sachen blieb nicht macht für ihn jetzt
in die bestelle wir müssen erstmal
wieder die kategorien zählen das
irgendwie also wir gucken jetzt mal
wieder wie viele verschiedene kategorien
gibt es gibt 66 kategorien und wir
lassen uns jetzt sagen aus welcher wir
bestellen zeigt mir eine zahl zwischen 1
ok bisher war irgendwie immer bei der
bestell videos irgendwas hinten warum
man hatte schon so eine vorahnung
neuanfang ist sein oder das müsse
irgendwas stimmt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 uhr
schreit äthiopisch leute nicht wüssten
nicht also hätte man nicht gefragt ob es
ein äthiopisches restaurant köln gibt
geben es gibt eine millionen menschen
aber äthiopisch irgendwie habe ich immer
ihre kategorien arbeitet die gehen jetzt
mal auf türkisch kann es ja nur ein oder
zwei richtung ausgeben es gibt momentan
keine lieferungen schade schade
wir müssen von 10 ist eine schöne runde
zahlt okay kommt mir meine sache
13 das ist einfach äthiopisch auflaufen
ich okay ich auch bin ich dabei aber auf
lauf kann man auch wieder jede küche
seiner italienischen sports mit air
france und richtig gramm siegerteam des
sein das wäre gewiss keine brücke lasst
uns leyen schon auflaufen
wieso auftrag könnte alles sein es ist
einfach noch ein restaurant pizza pasta
vier sterne tausend bewertungen erst
einmal wird auf fünf europa was sind das
für ihren preise aber das muss mal
gucken nur kategorie aufwerfe ja ok
gespannt bin ich dabei ja das ist übel
ist günstig für kölner verhältnisse
wir zählen die kategorien beliebte
gerichte wie immer nicht dabei fünf
verschiedene kategorien sagen eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 5 1 den salat gibt es
heute für mich und das liebe ich und das
ist wirklich einfach mal so sagen eine
zahl zwischen 1 und 8 3 auch rucola
pyjama die nummer 8 langwierig ist ein
bisschen gut ich würde mir selten
einfach so unterlag gestellt aber damit
war der 3
tomaten käse zwiebeln gurken thunfisch
meist gut an
ich finde das übel skarke übrigens mit
einer stellen können wenn ich es mit
truthahn schicken bestellt mag eine
kundin so unbedingt im salat teuer aber
ich bin kompliziert denn erst dann wird
für mich der leckere capriccio salat und
können wir man zwei nummer zwei pizza
hast du willst so ich bin wirklich ein
bisschen neidisch original so heldt
lasst uns mal schauen wie viele
verschiedene gibt es 12 334 wenn du die
pizza weg 10 34 verschiedene pizza
angebot das man das auch essen
das ist was ich gar nicht schmecken
donnerstag gehabt so wie ich gerade sagt
mir eine zahlt sich rund 30 19 und wir
mittendrin wir möglichst viel zählen
müssen sehr sehr gut auberginen und
angel sein dass du dich ja oder
auberginen auf pizza hätte ich jetzt
nicht gefühlt aber du hast natürlich
glück muss ich weiter mit meinen salat
als sieben euro das sind das sind
heftige preise für kölner verhältnisse
finde ich wirklich sondern irgendwas
drittes dazu auf probier basis sagt mir
eine zeit zwischen 1 und 6 die drei
ausläufe wir doch hier aufläuft wie oft
ich finde richtig gut dass nur fünf
verschiedene sachen ich fand alles neue
sondertopf weniger bleibt die
überbackenen konnten die takino auch
interessant sagt mir eine zeit zwischen
1 uhr und tortellini die zahlen dazu
gibt es nicht
hast du dich besonders gefreut über die
also ich finde nämlich oft hilft nichts
für mit die bis nach neujahr rastet man
schon mal aus mit ja gut wir haben jetzt
gefundene business bestellen heute linie
die takino das ist also eine stelle und
kartoffelsalat meine pizza wlan sahne
für lara tortellini takino für mich
keine lieferkosten 21 euro für drei
sachen absolut legend finde ich wir
bestellen und dann sehen uns gleich
wieder zurück
es ist soweit das essen ist angekommen
ging ok schnell also standard auf 15
minuten es hat ein bisschen gedauert
jedem fall aber wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen weiter weg sind so leute der
salat hier sieht jetzt nicht so ultra
gaildorf oder muss man schon sagen ich
will das ipad ist ganzes geschnittenes
aber okay man muss sich vorstellen dass
jemand bestellt herstellt frist racing
kam ja so extra dazu das macht dann
gleich darüber und hier haben wir den
auflauf einmal da bin ich sehr gespannt
nichts in dieser bestellung hätte ich
ohne dieses video jemals bestellt der
salat hätte ich nicht bestellt und
auberginen
aber er hatte ja also das riecht
irgendwie mit dem verbrannt und es sieht
auch ein bisschen verband aus
ja das hatte aber wir wollen mal nicht
zur vorträge beurteilt gucken wir uns
noch die pizza an die sie gut es ist ja
so lieder aus ja okay und fangen wir an
weil ich dachte so seien für das gebiet
wird dann können wir mal dass es noch
ein stück hinnehmen
ich finde ist die ganz falsch aus berlin
auf der pizza ja ein bisschen ja ein
bisschen ein bisschen lw irgendwie was
ist für mich so eine 4 uhr nachts
lieferservice pizza beißen wenn man sie
früher im club früher sage ich schon
wenn man von dem jahren war und so nach
hause kommen und hatte noch einen
lieferservice auch das so an ist ja also
was soll man dazu sagen es irgendwie so
ein bisschen gespart an so tomatensoße
und sony ging nicht darauf ein bisschen
bitter aber man ist echt ewig langer so
ein stück trockenes der pizza will ich
jetzt eine sechseinhalb von zehn geben
ja natürlich eine sieben aufgaben wahr
die es günstig war enttäuscht aber echt
ein bisschen bisher bin ich auch
gespannt aber wird personen leichte
schicht darum braucht dann seinen die
masse
ich habe jetzt auch alles auf dem auf
der gabel
[Musik]
das ist für mich auf jeden fall eine 4
von 10 3 ja das ist halt so nicht sagen
irgendwie das fleisch vom ja also das
hähnchen da sollen wir etwa wirklich
trocken aber es ist auch so nicht
gewünscht also überhaupt gar kein vorne
liefert aber der war super die platin
und serie fort an der tür aber keiner
ahnt was die sache also weil es halt
nicht
es ist durch nichts sagen so schmeckt so
das einzige was man wirklich raus
schmeckt ist der kessel
das kriegt von mir als eigentlich es ist
es ist eigentlich ekelhaft oder so
schmeckt dann einfach nach nichts und
deshalb kriegt von mir ne vier von zehn
also es ist niemals langweilig dadurch
dass die karte so klein ist denkbar dass
das so wie man zum beispiel dass schon
andere liefe restauriert haben eine
kleine karte das stimmt aber alles so
also eigentlich eine kleine karte mit
qualitätsmerkmal dachte ich zumindest
immer aber das enttäuscht wirklich ein
bisschen wie pizza sieht eigentlich
endlich da war es noch um den salat
musste ich mich jetzt auch noch an waren
aber das ist wirklich so
zwiebel keule vorleute gesetz gehört
diese pizza essen da oben drauf muss
also davon bin ich natürlich überhaupt
gar kein fan muss ich ehrlich sagen dass
ersten wo ich mit story bestellt aber
auch wirklich eine ziemlich enttäuschend
aber das hier ist halt einfach schlecht
hier leute probiert man ja wissen von
dem salat er ist auf jeden fall fast
alles mit auf der gabel bisschen
thunfisch bisschen käse wissen salat
weil dadurch alles reduktionen schwarze
oliven diesen scheiben tomate noch wird
ja was soll ich sagen es ist ein
bisschen so wie ich mir das vorstelle
das zweite play einfach also ich hab
halt auch hunger rät deshalb es ist auch
auf jeden fall auch aber wir haben alles
zusammen 21 euro das muss man auch sehen
also heute abschließend 7 von 10 4 von
10 414 ich glaube es ist mit die
schlechte bewertung bisher es war auch
einfach nicht also kann ich nicht anders
sein
noch also doch freund einen
lieferservice aber er macht einfach
besser bist du noch was sagen das letzte
wort bis zum nächsten